This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Downtown Oakland, where we work, is beautiful. But it doesn't cut a very distinct skyline. Sure, they're the cranes down by the port, and those are pretty famous. But in terms of downtown Oakland proper, there's pretty much just one building that defines the nighttime skyline. The Tribune Tower. It used to be the headquarters of the newspaper, the Oakland Tribune. The paper moved up the street, so now the tower is an office building. That's producer Avery Truffleman. The Tribune Tower, which happens to be right by our office, was the tallest building in
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。我们工作的奥克兰市中心很美，但它的天际线并不算特别鲜明。当然，港口边有起重机，那些很有名。但就奥克兰市中心本身而言，几乎只有一栋建筑定义了夜间天际线，那就是论坛报大厦。它曾经是《奥克兰论坛报》的总部。报社搬到了街上，所以现在这座大厦是一栋办公楼。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。论坛报大厦恰好就在我们办公室旁边，它是20世纪20年代奥克兰最高的建筑。
Oakland in the 1920s. It's a 22 story tower, topped with a copper coated, pitched, man-sered roof, and a sandy brick exterior. It's a really unique architecture, but that is not why it's the most distinctive building in Oakland. It's famous because it says Tribune in gigantic orange-red neon letters on all four sides of the building, and each side has a neon clock with neon hands. And it's always on every night, never flickering, rarely as a letter out. Because the Tribune neon has a secret weapon, on the top, top floor of the tower. Take the elevator to the 20th floor.
它是一座22层高的大厦，顶部覆盖着铜皮、倾斜的曼萨德式屋顶，外墙是沙色的砖块。它的建筑风格非常独特，但这并不是它成为奥克兰最独特建筑的原因。它之所以出名，是因为大厦的四面都用巨大的橙红色霓虹灯写着“Tribune”（论坛报），每一面都有一个带霓虹灯指针的霓虹灯时钟。而且它每晚都亮着，从不闪烁，也很少有字母熄灭。因为论坛报的霓虹灯在大厦的最顶层有一个秘密武器。乘电梯到20楼。
There you'll see a door. Restricted area limited access. And there's a flight of narrow stairs. Up the stairs, you'll find a man. John? Hi. Hey there. John Law, the keeper of the neon.
在那里你会看到一扇门。写着“限制区域，禁止进入”。还有一段狭窄的楼梯。顺着楼梯上去，你会发现一个人。约翰？嗨。嘿。约翰·劳，霓虹灯的守护者。
We are on the 22nd floor of the Oakland Tribune Tower. I have a tiny office space in one corner and the current owners, I have a wonderful arrangement with them and you know we rent the place from them and I keep there's neon signs going. By trade John Law is a sign installer and maintainer and he is the one that keeps the Tribune Tower neon blazing. Nowadays a wrap around neon clock on the 20th floor of a building is fairly rare. There were more in the 30s and 40s. They built a lot more buildings with the signage on them in the end. They're almost all gone.
我们现在在奥克兰论坛报大厦的22楼。我在角落里有一个小办公室，现任业主与我达成了很棒的协议，我们从他们那里租下这个地方，我负责让霓虹灯保持亮着。约翰·劳的职业是霓虹灯安装和维护人员，他就是那个让论坛报大厦霓虹灯闪耀的人。如今，大厦20楼的环绕式霓虹灯时钟相当罕见。在30和40年代，这种时钟更多。那时他们建造了更多带有这种标志的建筑。最终，它们几乎都消失了。
The Tribune neon, like many, many neon signs, has had periods of darkness and neglect. Most signs of this size have been allowed to flicker out and die. But thanks to John and the owner of the tower, the Tribune Neon, after a period of neglect, has been inconsistently since the late 90s, and this is no small feat. This is back of one of the four clock, so watch your head. John can repair some of the Neon from within the tower. But if I have to get out on the face and work on the Neon, on the letters, I have to clip into, I have a full body harness, and kind of step onto the face of the tower. But if I have to get out on the face and work on the neon on the letters, I have to clip in, I have a full body harness and kind of step onto the face of the letter. We would put hanging over a drop.
论坛报的霓虹灯，像许多许多霓虹灯一样，也经历过黑暗和被忽视的时期。大多数这种规模的标志都被任由其闪烁熄灭并最终报废。但多亏了约翰和大厦业主，论坛报的霓虹灯在经历了一段被忽视的时期后，自90年代末以来一直断断续续地亮着，这绝非易事。这是四个时钟之一的背面，小心你的头。约翰可以在大厦内部修理一些霓虹灯。但如果我必须到外面去修理霓虹灯，修理那些字母，我就必须扣上安全扣，我有一套全身安全带，然后踏上大厦的表面。但如果我必须到外面去修理字母上的霓虹灯，我就必须扣上安全扣，我有一套全身安全带，然后踏上字母的表面。我们就像悬挂在深渊之上。
A drop of something like 300 feet. But John loves heights. And he loves neon. There's nothing like neon. I mean, other light sources, they don't have that kind of fuzzy, otherworldly look to it that you get with neon. And neon signage, you know, can be very beautiful. And a lot of people in the past have considered to be cheesy and ugly
大约300英尺的深渊。但约翰热爱高处。他也热爱霓虹灯。没有什么能比得上霓虹灯。我的意思是，其他光源没有霓虹灯那种模糊的、超凡脱俗的外观。而且霓虹灯标志，你知道，可以非常漂亮。过去很多人认为它俗气又丑陋，
and representative of some dying commercialism that they found unpleasant. People like philosophers, essayists, writing critiques of late capitalism, they use neon as a metaphor to express their distaste for the neon hell that we all live in. Christoph Rabat is the author of Flickering Light, a history of neon. And I teach American studies at the University of Patabong in Germany. For Professor Rabat to study neon, it's to study America.
并且代表了某种他们觉得令人不快的垂死商业主义。像哲学家、散文家这样的人，在撰写对晚期资本主义的批判时，他们用霓虹灯作为隐喻，来表达他们对我们所生活的这个“霓虹地狱”的厌恶。克里斯托弗·拉巴特是《闪烁之光：霓虹灯史》的作者。我在德国帕德博恩大学教授美国研究。对于拉巴特教授来说，研究霓虹灯就是研究美国。
A blinking in the night in some American diner. That's just something if you're coming from a European background, it has a really kind of aesthetic power to it. It is a great metaphor of American culture, even though it's not an American product, per se. The gas neon was discovered in 1898 by a British scientist named Sir William Ramsey. It was a new gas, so we named it for the Greek neos, meaning new. Ramsey realized that if he ran electricity through this new gas, it would burn bright, bright orangey red. But he basically said, oh, that's cool, and then forgot about it, moving on to find other gases and ultimately win a Nobel Prize.
在某个美国餐馆里闪烁的灯光。如果你来自欧洲背景，那确实有一种审美上的力量。它是美国文化的一个伟大隐喻，尽管它本身并非美国产品。霓虹气体是英国科学家威廉·拉姆齐爵士于1898年发现的。这是一种新气体，所以我们以希腊语“neos”命名它，意为“新”。拉姆齐意识到，如果他让电流通过这种新气体，它会发出明亮的橙红色光。但他基本上只是说，哦，那很酷，然后就把它忘了，继续去寻找其他气体，并最终获得了诺贝尔奖。
But neon lights, as we know them, were made and popularized by another chemist. It was this Frenchman, and he played around with these neon tubes. And it was a pretty good businessman and thought, well, we could do something with this. A Frenchman named George Claude made his first neon lights in 1910. And he eventually quit chemistry to start a business called Claude Neon. It was the first to sell this new lighting for decor and for advertising. The first Neon signs were up in Paris. Gabarbyshop was the first shop ever to have a Neon sign,
但我们所知的霓虹灯是由另一位化学家制造并推广的。那是这位法国人，他摆弄这些霓虹灯管。他是个相当不错的商人，心想，嗯，我们可以用这个做点什么。一位名叫乔治·克劳德的法国人在1910年制造了他的第一批霓虹灯。他最终放弃了化学，创办了一家名为“克劳德霓虹”的公司。它是第一家销售这种用于装饰和广告的新型照明设备的公司。第一批霓虹灯标志出现在巴黎。加巴比商店是第一家拥有霓虹灯标志的商店，
and then it really spread around the city of Paris. And from Paris, then it spread around the world. George Claude may have been the father of Neon lights, but he was not a good guy. Well, you know, it's hard to follow love with him. He turned to an ardent follower of Nazi Germany, a great businessman, but also doubtful morals. But Neon swept the United States. It was brighter and more efficient than incandescent lighting, and Americans were giddy with it. By 1924, the company Claude Neon
然后它真的传遍了巴黎全城。从巴黎开始，它又传遍了世界。乔治·克劳德可能是霓虹灯之父，但他不是个好人。嗯，你知道，很难对他产生好感。他成为了纳粹德国的狂热追随者，是个伟大的商人，但道德也令人怀疑。但霓虹灯席卷了美国。它比白炽灯更亮、更高效，美国人对它着迷不已。到1924年，“克劳德霓虹”公司
had franchises in 14 major cities across the country. By the 1930s, there were 20,000 Neon advertisements in Manhattan and Brooklyn, most of them, made by Claude Neon. Neon signs were the embodiment of prosperity, so Neon was on respectable upscale spots, like movie palace marques and opera houses, you know, nice places. So it started with the churches and the and the four stories and the Cardiola ships, you know, institutions that signified the luxury. Neon became the symbol of life in the big city. In the late 40s, Peggy Lee, you know, sing her in those days, she had a song. It was really the Sniyan enthusiasm of that period.
在全国14个主要城市设有特许经营店。到20世纪30年代，曼哈顿和布鲁克林有20,000个霓虹灯广告，其中大部分由“克劳德霓虹”制造。霓虹灯标志是繁荣的化身，所以霓虹灯出现在体面的高档场所，比如电影院的遮阳篷和歌剧院，你知道，那些不错的地方。所以它始于教堂、百货商店和卡迪奥拉船，你知道，那些象征奢华的机构。霓虹灯成为了大城市生活的象征。40年代末，佩吉·李，你知道，那个时代的歌手，她有一首歌。那确实是那个时期对霓虹灯的热情。
But the initial excitement fades, the popularity of downtown wanes. People move to the suburbs, the cities grow dark, the neon flickers. Years later, 10, 20 years down the road, then it was like more cheap bars, cheap hotels, and then it had this city quality to it. And then by and by, I'm trying to do this metaphor of people who, you know, more or less critiqued the loneliness in society. There's a lot of country in Western. Science that I always have someone getting drunk by the neon sign. There's a neon light at the end of the tone.
但最初的兴奋感逐渐消退，市中心的受欢迎程度下降。人们搬到郊区，城市变得黑暗，霓虹灯开始闪烁。多年后，10年、20年后，它就变成了更多廉价酒吧、廉价旅馆的标志，并带有一种城市特质。然后渐渐地，我试图用这个隐喻来形容那些或多或少批判社会孤独感的人。有很多乡村音乐和西部音乐的标志，总是有人在霓虹灯下喝醉。隧道尽头有一盏霓虹灯。
And suddenly neon, which used to be a sign of luxury, turns into a symbol of poverty and a rundown city. Neon is also hard to maintain, and a broken Neon sign is a bright, flashing sign of brokenness. And that's why it became the symbol of decay. If Neon tubes are made well, they can last about 30 years, sometimes up to 70, but they are a glass, so they can break, and they're out there in the elements, so the electricity can flicker out.
突然间，曾经作为奢华标志的霓虹灯，变成了贫困和破败城市的象征。霓虹灯也很难维护，而坏掉的霓虹灯标志是一个明亮、闪烁的破败信号。这就是为什么它成为了衰败的象征。如果霓虹灯管制作精良，它们可以使用约30年，有时长达70年，但它们是玻璃做的，所以可能会破碎，而且它们暴露在自然环境中，所以电流可能会闪烁熄灭。
When a neon sign goes out, you can't just screw in a new tube or order up a cheap replacement. You would think that it was like a machine-made product, right? That there was some sort of big neon factory that just turned out neon on an assembly line. And that's really not the case. It's really craftsmen who shaped these signs. They've been the tubes with their hands. And it's really just one person doing this. A person like Shana Peterson.
当霓虹灯标志熄灭时，你不能只是拧入一个新灯管或订购一个廉价的替代品。你可能会认为它像机器制造的产品，对吧？认为有什么大型霓虹灯工厂在流水线上生产霓虹灯。事实并非如此。真正塑造这些标志的是工匠。他们用双手弯曲灯管。而且通常只有一个人在做这件事。像莎娜·彼得森这样的人。
A neon glass blower is not a glass blower. It's really called neon tube bending. That's the trade. We're two benders. Shawna Peterson has been bending since 1987. She says color is a good way to code these signs, to know what's inside of them, and what quality they are. Red neon lights are the most basic and the most popular. And that's like a reddish orange, and that's the standard neon red. That is pure neon
霓虹灯玻璃吹制工并不是吹玻璃的。这实际上被称为“霓虹灯管弯曲”。这就是这门手艺。我们是灯管弯曲工。莎娜·彼得森自1987年以来一直从事弯曲工作。她说颜色是编码这些标志的好方法，可以知道里面装的是什么，以及它们的质量如何。红色霓虹灯是最基础也是最受欢迎的。那是红橙色，那是标准的霓虹红。那是纯霓虹
gas. It just naturally burns that color. And then there's blue neon, also pretty basic. The cool secret about blue neon is that it's not actually neon gas. It's argon gas right in with a little mercury, but we still call them neon signs. And for a while, almost all neon signs were just red and blue. Pure neon or argon mercury in clear tubes. Then the industry came up with a way to make any color you want. There's a phosphor powder coating on it inside of the tubes. Benders can use tubes with different phosphors on the inside of the tubes to create more colors than just red and blue. Use a few, use a green, a lime green, go for a lime green, you know, use of color, done well, it's nice. Now just to be clear, those neon beer signs at the
气体。它自然就会发出那种颜色。然后是蓝色霓虹灯，也相当基础。关于蓝色霓虹灯的酷秘密是，它实际上并不是霓虹气体。它是氩气加上一点汞，但我们仍然称它们为霓虹灯标志。有一段时间，几乎所有的霓虹灯标志都只有红色和蓝色。透明灯管中的纯霓虹或氩汞。后来，工业界想出了一种制造任何你想要颜色的方法。灯管内部有荧光粉涂层。弯曲工可以使用内部带有不同荧光粉的灯管，创造出比红色和蓝色更多的颜色。用几种，用一种绿色，一种酸橙绿，追求酸橙绿，你知道，颜色的运用，做得好，就很漂亮。现在要明确一点，那些在
bodega, or those standard open signs, can be, and often are, made on a massive scale in China. Those are still hand-blown, that's the only way to make neon. But that's like one person makes only the letter E all day long. Another person makes only O's. And these signs are lower quality. Cheap signs for beer brands or generic open signs are often colored with a coating of color plastic on the outside of the glass tubes. Usually it's so cheap you can chip it off with your fingernail. But if you're looking at a sign over your local bar or hotel or sometimes even a neon
杂货店里的霓虹啤酒标志，或者那些标准的“营业中”标志，可以而且通常是在中国大规模生产的。那些仍然是手工吹制的，那是制造霓虹灯的唯一方法。但这就像一个人整天只做字母E。另一个人只做O。这些标志质量较低。啤酒品牌的廉价标志或通用的“营业中”标志通常在玻璃管外部涂上一层彩色塑料。通常它太便宜了，你用指甲就能把它刮掉。但如果你看到当地酒吧或旅馆上方的标志，有时甚至是连锁店上方的霓虹
sign over a chain store, if it's large and you haven't seen it anywhere else, it was probably painstakingly crafted, probably locally. Neon 2 benders get glass from the manufacturer in 4 foot long tubes and they draw out a pattern for how they bend and fuse it. You're bending the word apple, you never start with A. You have to map out in your mind where those curves are and how they're going to change direction and generally you're going to start somewhere in the center of that word
标志，如果它很大，而且你在其他任何地方都没见过，那它很可能是精心制作的，很可能是本地制作的。霓虹灯管弯曲工从制造商那里获得4英尺长的玻璃管，他们画出弯曲和熔合的图案。你在弯曲“apple”这个词时，永远不会从A开始。你必须在脑海中规划出那些曲线在哪里，它们将如何改变方向，通常你会从那个词的中心某处开始，
and work your way out. And Shawna has a number of different burners and tools to manipulate the tubes. To bend a curve, so hold the glass tube on either end over an open flame burner. When I'm using it, it sounds like this. Shana has only a few seconds to bend the glass into a perfect shape before it hardens up again, so she has to act quickly and precisely.
然后向外延伸。莎娜有许多不同的燃烧器和工具来处理灯管。要弯曲一条曲线，就把玻璃管的两端放在明火燃烧器上。当我使用它时，听起来是这样的。莎娜只有几秒钟的时间把玻璃弯曲成完美的形状，然后它就会变硬，所以她必须迅速而精确地行动。
Sneezing is a tube ender's nightmare. Then Shana processes the bent tubes with a machine called a bimbarder. It's this whole process where she heats up the tubes really, really hot and vacuums out the impurities before filling the tubes with neon or argon mercury and fuses the electrical source to them. That include summary is the craft. It's expensive, it's difficult, and there aren't that many people who can make neon
打喷嚏是灯管弯曲工的噩梦。然后莎娜用一种叫“轰击机”的机器处理弯曲的灯管。这是一个完整的过程，她把灯管加热得非常非常热，并在填充霓虹或氩汞之前抽走杂质，然后将电源熔合到灯管上。这就是这门手艺的总结。它昂贵、困难，而且没有多少人能制造霓虹
signs. And that is why. When they break, they usually get replaced with LEDs. LEDs is so much cheaper, and people in the LED industry would tell you it's so much brighter as well. Randall Ann Homan and Al Barna are the publishers and photographers of a book called San Francisco neon, Survivors and Lost icons. All of these signs are part of our cultural heritage
灯标志。这就是原因。当它们坏掉时，通常会被LED取代。LED便宜得多，LED行业的人会告诉你它也亮得多。兰德尔·安·霍曼和阿尔·巴纳是《旧金山霓虹灯：幸存者与失落的图标》一书的出版商和摄影师。所有这些标志都是我们文化遗产的一部分，
in San Francisco and their treasures, and we need to hang onto them. Randall and Al lead tours of some of their favorite neon around the city. Let's stop here. Many of the signs are defunct or hangover businesses that they're no longer affiliated with. All right, so this is my very favorite sign.
在旧金山，它们是宝藏，我们需要守护它们。兰德尔和阿尔带领人们参观他们在城市中一些最喜欢的霓虹灯。我们在这里停一下。许多标志已经废弃或属于它们不再关联的企业。好了，这是我最喜欢的标志。
This Art Deco peacock has no fewer than 17 concentric circles of neon and it's really a feat of tube-ending. Now, the business is long gone. It's kind of a miracle that it's still here. San Francisco was once covered in neon. Look at an old picture of Market Street from the 1950s and you'll see it looks like the Vegas Strip, all a glow with flashing lights. Then, in the 60s, there was a campaign to get rid of all that flash and beautify that
这只装饰艺术风格的孔雀拥有不少于17个同心霓虹圆圈，这确实是灯管弯曲的杰作。现在，这家企业早已不复存在。它还能留在这里简直是个奇迹。旧金山曾经被霓虹灯覆盖。看看20世纪50年代市场街的老照片，你会发现它看起来像拉斯维加斯大道，到处都是闪烁的灯光。然后，在60年代，有一场运动旨在消除所有那些闪光，美化那个
part of town, and almost all those neon signs were removed. And around the rest of the city, pretty regularly, stops on Randall and Al's neon tour will just vanish. Yeah, it's embarrassing and awkward to bring a tour group around the corner to talk about a sign that doesn't exist anymore. It kind of illustrates the nature of neon signs. If you're interested in photographing them or painting them, do it as quick as you can because they can disappear overnight.
城镇的部分地区，几乎所有的霓虹灯标志都被拆除了。而在城市的其他地方，兰德尔和阿尔的霓虹灯之旅的站点经常会消失。是的，带一个旅游团转过街角去谈论一个不再存在的标志，这很尴尬。这在某种程度上说明了霓虹灯标志的本质。如果你有兴趣拍摄或绘画它们，请尽快行动，因为它们可能一夜之间消失。
And it's not just San Francisco. New York also went from having tens of thousands of signs in the 1970s to just a couple hundred today. Hong Kong is losing a lot of its spectacular neon displays. Signs change with their cities. But in some spheres, neon is having a little revival. The few neon benders around are getting a lot of business from high-end restaurants and hotels, companies who aren't quotes illuminated on their walls, or artists who are commissioning neon pieces.
这不仅仅是旧金山。纽约也从1970年代拥有数万个标志，变成了今天只有几百个。香港正在失去许多壮观的霓虹灯展示。标志随着城市而改变。但在某些领域，霓虹灯正在经历一点复兴。为数不多的霓虹灯弯曲工正从高端餐厅和酒店、那些希望墙上被“照亮”的公司，或者委托制作霓虹灯艺术品的艺术家那里获得大量业务。
Now a custom neon sign represents an emphasis on craftsmanship and style, tinged with a bit of nostalgia, ensure this all sounds very artisanal and stuff, but this might just be the way that neon craft survives. At its core, the ingredients are simple, glass, electricity, and gas from the air we breathe. And the results bend into something spectacular. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Kirk Colstad, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Jim Rizzo of Neon Works in Oakland and Tom Downs, author of Walking
现在，定制的霓虹灯标志代表了对工艺和风格的强调，带有一丝怀旧色彩。确保这一切听起来非常手工，但这可能正是霓虹灯工艺生存下去的方式。其核心成分很简单：玻璃、电力和我们呼吸的空气中的气体。结果弯曲成了壮观的东西。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、柯克·科尔斯塔德和我罗曼·马斯参与。本周特别感谢奥克兰Neon Works的吉姆·里佐和《行走旧金山》的作者汤姆·唐斯。
San Francisco. Randall and Al's photography book, San Francisco Neon, Survivors, and Lost Icons is now in its third printing. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-LW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, an architecture and interior's firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but you can listen to every single episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
兰德尔和阿尔的摄影集《旧金山霓虹灯：幸存者与失落的图标》现已第三次印刷。我们是91.7 K-A-LW旧金山的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司Arxan的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，但你可以在99pi.org收听《99%隐形》的每一集。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。